let me go home
cherries are perfect all right so here's
the deal I've been obsessed with this
game Animal Crossing and I played it on
GameCube it was fine whatever I was
didn't get bad obsessed and I played it
again we and now Animal Crossing you
leave is out I don't even know how to
explain this game choose if you've never
really played it you are a mayor of a
town and there's animals who are also in
your town and you have to make them
happy and you give them things and visit
their houses and it sounds so stupid
it's a stupid game I've ever played and
let me tell you what I freakin love it
I'm honestly disgusted with myself I am
in a very dark place
right now I'm not really but when I'm
playing this game I feel as though I am
because it isn't sucking my life away I
am so busy but every free second I have
basically if there's a moment that I'm
idle and I have nothing else to do I
will have this with me you do these
random tasks every day like you're
watering plants you pick fruit you
expand your house you got to pay off
your mortgage so that you can expand
your home and get bigger rooms and more
stuff dig holes and shake trees when you
tell people these things they're really
confused like how is this fun I don't
know I don't know I can't figure it out
when I talk to other people who were
also playing this game we just sit there
and we start talking it's like yo what's
your native fruit I'm like yeah what's
up mine's cherries you know then you can
open your gate to your town and then
they can come and you guys can Vivat and
you can dig up fossils together and
catch bugs and catch fish and shake
trees and potentially some bells will
fall out of them which is the currency
in these towns and then if you're really
having a good day you can go to the
island where you can get all sorts of
really good fruits you can dive you can
catch fishes under the water and oh
there's more you could do all kinds of
little mini games where there's the
fossil Cod I think I'm losing my mind I
think I've lost my mind
so I started posting a couple gameplay
videos on my gaming channel shoot I
wanted to take all this stuff actually
to the museum that
and I said something about oh I wonder
if I can see how many hours I've played
oh gosh you can 71 hours since the game
has come out and probably by the time I
post this video I'll probably have
another 10 or 20 editors notes I'm
currently 88 hours into Animal Crossing
ooh what am I doing with my life and
discuss it discussing if I would apply
myself in life the amount that I applied
myself in this stupid meaningless game I
would be the mayor of a real freakin
town I am gonna be the next president
I'm gonna be the next president I'm
gonna be running whenever it is yeah I
got a run for president I should
probably start now but the amount of
time and effort that I've put into
basically doing nothing accomplishing
nothing at this point I don't even think
I'm enjoying the game anymore because I
wake up two hours early so I can collect
all of my goods my shops don't open
until ten o'clock a.m. so I've got all
this time to kill all this time to kill
I can do real work and then the shops
close at like 9:00 p.m. so if I'm not
constantly on all day long I can't do
all the things that I need to do so many
of you guys have played Animal Crossing
or know someone who is obsessed with
this stupid game stupid I love it oh god
send them this video because just let
them know that they're not alone and
maybe you couldn't understand or not
understand because probably by watching
us you think I'm even more crazy than I
already a.m.
I'm gonna go shake some trees and dig
some holes doo doo doo doo doo how's it
going buddy he stayed up late last night
and I sleep afraid she won't talk to me
I was up no shut up no I don't want you
to come over anytime for us
[Music]